haha the Joe Rogan experience it's kind
of how I feel about the that's why I've
been staying home you know for the whole
world we just need we need to lock in
it's gonna this is gonna be the the
honeypot that gets us to enter the
virtual reality this is gonna be the
honeypot like do you want to deal with
viruses
there's no viruses in this world hmm
your sole carry on so what do I even
know what about what Edward Snowden I
believe I've been researched this by
heard he was saying that this is sort of
a an attempt to get us to get implanted
with you know biological testing have
her phone set up more to follow us as
this you know is there any sort of this
is a reality of human nature thank you
he's a brilliant God any time there's an
opening for people to take advantage of
that opening anytime there's a moment
that happens where there's some
scrambling and maybe they can gather up
more power maybe they can gather more
surveillance tools maybe they can make
it easier to do things that they'd like
to do that have nothing to do like the
Patriot Act like they did there's a lot
of stuff for the Patriot Act that had
nothing to do with terrorism they just
decided let's add some stuff and let's
control these one of the [ __ ] they
always want to control people Pete it's
hard to control people and as the
population gets bigger as time goes on
they slowly give in to this idea of
controlling people more and more so
they're going to definitely use this as
a way to ensure that you know they have
some sort of extended reach whether it's
some sort of a reach to make sure that
you're vaccinated or some sort of a
reach to make sure that your your
antibodies are clear some sort of a
reach to make sure that you're not
drinking are you because if you drink
you get your immune system shattered if
your immune system [ __ ] up what if you
get sick and you pass it on to your
friends if you're drinking you're being
a bad citizen like who the [ __ ] knows
what could happen once someone's
tracking whether or not you're healthy
what are you doing man I see you've only
slept seven hours last night like what's
that all about Tom all right to have an
hour's not a lot of sleep in you know do
you not love your neighbors do you want
to get sick
now do you sense or does or any been any
evidence that that is happening now that
there is with our phones specifically to
do you know the phone's tracking it is
heard like I think well the concept of
it is definitely available right the
concept of it of contact tracking is
being talked about openly and then if if
a company ensures if they figured out
like say if like there was a place you
go right this would be kind of
interesting so save there's a place you
go Tom green you go and they give you a
vaccination once the vaccination becomes
available and you know that you now
don't have to worry about getting this
thing so we can track all the people
that have been vaccinated as long as you
sign up for the app and all the people
not be vaccinated you see them and you
see them on the app oh my god well
before we stepped in this mall let's see
what kind of shitty [ __ ] citizens
there are that haven't been vaccinated
or maybe you're not allowed in the mall
yeah yeah and you'll be able to find
them on a map and it'll get real weird
yeah it's like it's another step a
really quick step in dragging us into
the machine
and to take away you know the the
nuances of just human life that we're
accustomed to and it become more and
more digitized and organized and people
need freedom man and if you don't have
the freedom to just be somewhere without
the government knowing that you're there
like if you haven't committed any crime
you're not a criminal and if they could
just monitor you and you've never
committed any crime that that is a weird
place that's weird
things are getting weird you're supposed
to be you're supposed to be following
criminals only and I know it makes it
easier for you to follow criminals if
you could follow everybody but you were
changing what everybody is you're
changing what people are if you follow
them all the time everywhere they go if
you listen to everything that they ever
say through the microphone and their
[ __ ] phone you're changing what they
are and you're making them scared and
everybody knows it and no one wants to
admit it you're making people scared and
people do things because they don't want
censorship they don't want to be
censored they'll only yell at they
self-censor they don't want to be not in
compliance it changes their behavior mmm
we all know that we all know that it's
dangerous to creativity dangerous to
authenticity is
dangerous to so many things it's not
it's not a good way to be as a person
like looking over your shoulder people
are watching all the time it's to aware
this is too weird
it's too weird and to force the whole
and then who's got control that the
government like what some people that
got elected to a position the only ones
they get to look in on everybody well
and then what if that opens up was they
know everybody can look at it and
everybody [ __ ] it the Information Act we
just got a given the evitable time gonna
watch your [ __ ] I'm gonna watch your
[ __ ] from you toaster cuz your toaster
your electric toothbrush that knows
whether or not have cavities is
listening in while you [ __ ] not a pretty
sight yeah it's almost like we're taking
a step closer and closer towards the
digital world with this and that's I
don't I'm not a conspiracy theorist in
the sense that I don't I don't I don't
think that robots are out to get us
I don't think that the electronic world
is looking to consume us but I am
concerned with some steps that we could
take that make our life more digital to
take away too much of what it means to
be a person some what it means to be a
person is like fun there's this there's
fun and the weirdness of the world
there's fun in the danger of the world
you take away all that [ __ ] with apps
right and and alerts and you know and
like where I can't go down that Street
there's a guy down that Street that was
arrested at one point in time [ __ ] like
what well yeah we're gonna we're gonna
lose out all the mystery of life for
safety and then we become what would
have become these unromantic boring
[ __ ]
digital things that are locked into
pleasure sources things that pump them
pleasure because they take in the place
you know I mean really they could do
that if they could get to a point where
you wear an implant it just keeps your
dopamine levels up at a very high high
note you get augmented reality glasses
where everybody's hot it'd be pretty
cool might be might be better than not
yes like that might be better if they
lie to you like the matrix remember when
that one dude was given into the matrix
and he's like look I just want to be an
important person don't be like an actor
or some memories right he's you want to
taste steak again
yeah who's eating steak right
yeah maybe maybe he's right
[Applause]